let's bring in our military analyst
former senior intelligence and security
officer Philip Ingram so Philip a lot
developing this afternoon as while we've
been on air in Sudan just bring us up to
date with the background to these
clashes why have they broken out now
it seems complex but it's really quite
simple it started a rivalry between
these two men you know we've got the
Army General General Abdul fatal
al-buran
um on the on the right here and the
general in charge of the rapid support
forces General Muhammad hamdan Del Lago
also known as hemeti and that's that's
him on the left here and they've been
working together since they overthrew
the president president albashir in 2019
and had a joint government with a
civilian Administration until 2021 when
they threw out the civilian
Administration and they were the
military effectively military Junta
since since then there's been growing
pressure from the civilian population to
bring in frame Fair elections and to
have civilian oversight of the military
and to fold this rsf a paramilitary
organization that's got some quite nasty
links to other activities around into
the army and get it under civilian
control and bring a number of other
issues under control they haven't been
good bad fellows the rsf have refused to
fall into the army because there hasn't
been any decision as to who would lead
it and that's why this all kicked off
after our social media post on Saturday
morning and what's the latest then on
the ground in the capital cartoon notice
on the ground cartoons confused is the
best way to describe it we've got
fighting started yesterday morning
around cartoon International Airport
there's a was a joint military base
between the Army and rsf um in the in
that area and fighting continues there
and of course up around the presidential
Palace two key seats of par on both
sides are claiming that they got control
of it as well as some other sites across
the rest of the country I think many
people will be wondering what do these
clashes tell us then about the relations
between the Sudanese Army and also the
rsf well it shows that there's a real
fault line that's in there and the thing
that triggered
um the the move to the current problems
were both signing a framework agreement
on the 5th of December last year and
that outlined how they would transition
into civilian oversight and bring in
free and fair elections in a two-year
time period Army General was felt that
he was pressurized into it um they
blamed the International Community
that's going on and really what they
wanted in that is civilian Tech
civilians again oversight of the
military
um the rsf to be folded into the regular
army but they hadn't worked out who was
in charge of that and that's quite
important because the Army has got
control over some of the lucrative
country Holdings and agriculture
industry and everything else so that's
where the big money lies and then there
was a final bit into looking at just
Justice going back to the Dual far
conflict in 2003 so this is called real
friction and it's only just starting to
play out at the moment Philip thank you
for an update Philip Ingram there